il est le troisième soldat français mort
en Irak au mois d'août lundi dernier 28
août alors que son unité appuyait un
groupe irakien en opération
anti-terroriste le sergent Nicolas
Mazier est tombé sous le feu ennemi à
une centaine de kilomètres au nord de
Bagdad alors que les soldats étaient en
reconnaissance en appui des forces
irakiennes il a été mortellement touché
lors d'un échange de tir la présidence
française a fait part de la vie émotion
du président de la République à
l'annonce de la mort du sergent du
commando parachutiste de l'air n°10 et
Emmanuel Macron a par ailleurs réagi sur
X le sergent Nicolas Mazier se battait
pour la France pour notre sécurité tombé
en Irak c'est toute la nation qui le
pleurent le ministre des Armées ainsi
que le chef d'état-major des armées ont
eux aussi rendu hommage aux soldats
mardi le second saluant son engagement
et son courage 4 autres militaires
français ont été blessés dans cette
opération plutôt dans le mois dimanche
20 août Nicolas latourte adjudant du
sixième régiment du génie d'Angers tombé
lors d'un exercice opérationnel le 18
août le sergent Baptiste gaucho issu du
ne devienne régiment du génie avait
trouvé la mort dans un accident de
circulation après la mort de ces 3
militaires français le président
Emmanuel Macron a redit à l'Irak sa
détermination à combattre le groupe état
islamique lors d'un entretien avec le
Premier ministre irakien a annoncé
mercredi 30 août l'Élysée environ 600
militaires français sont déployés en
Irak dans le cadre de l'opération Chamal
depuis 2014 qui comprend un volet
formation et conseil des forces
irakiennes et un volet appui aérien au
profit de la coalition internationale
inhérente résolve contre le groupe état
islamique créé en 2014 en mars un haut
responsable militaire irakien assurait
que daesh acronyme en arabe de l'État
islamique comptait encore entre 400 et
500 combattants actifs en Irak